[Music]
after decades in the making bill and ted
are finally back to face the music
both in theaters and on streaming at
home where viewers can pause and rewind
to catch the little things
here are a few small details that you
might have missed in bill and ted face
the music
fans first meet villain ted's children
at the end of bill and ted's bogus
journey
when bill and ted returned to the battle
of the bands after 16 months of intense
guitar lessons
plus time off for their honeymoons each
married a princess from medieval england
and each
stepped on stage with a baby strapped to
his back
[Applause]
as we learn in bill and ted face the
music those were actually nicknames for
their daughters
wilhemina billy logan and theodora thea
preston played respectively by bridget
lundy payne
who you may recognize from bombshell and
samara weaving
from ready or not who happens to be the
niece of reeves matrix adversary
hugo weaving now i'm supposed to say hmm
that's interesting in bill and ted's
excellent adventure a representative
from the future named rufus felt
duty-bound to help the guys pass their
history exam because their music would
unite the universe
align the planets bring them into
harmony and allow meaningful contact
with all forms of life
not to mention ending war and poverty
and
it's excellent for dancing a few years
later in bill and ted's bogus journey
the guys debuted their super group wild
stallions
complete with death the grim reaper
himself on base but in the opening
moments of bill and ted face the music
viewers learned that he and the
stallions have parted ways
with a magazine touting a parting quote
from death fittingly
see you in hell the headline see you in
hell isn't just tabloid shorthand
however
later in the film bill and ted along
with their daughters
ted's father and a bunch of other people
from across space and time
all actually end up in hell where bill
and ted again
meet death judging by the decor in his
lair including a framed
wild stallion's jacket and album he's
missed his bandmates
even though at first he acts like he
hasn't
in its own loopy way bill and ted face
the music hits on the ambivalence and
regrets of middle age through our heroes
whose foretold promise hasn't yet
happened but not for lack of trying
years after their band's breakup the two
scramble for gigs
playing taco nights and even wedding
receptions such as the one for ted's
brother deacon
in an amusing turn ted's brother marries
missy
played by a returning amy stock who in
the earlier films married and divorced
both bill's father
and ted's father it's a development that
kind of makes deacon his own
father-in-law much to his real dad's
disgust
the reception gives bill and ted the
chance to show off a variety of musical
styles they've learned in pursuit of the
ultimate song
including the trumpet kettle drums
bagpipes
throat singing and the theremin
unfamiliar with some of those
billy and thea aren't while their dads
might have called
beethoven beef oven back in the day the
girls know their stuff
and bill and ted have studied a lot too
while complimenting their dads on the
much-maligned wedding performance
thea and billy drop some deep knowledge
about musical history
even exceptionally obscure music history
their easy dispensing of music trivia
informs how the two are so easily able
to go on their own
excellent adventure through time in a
most casual way assembling a band for
bill and ted's big show
when thea compliments her uncle ted she
tells him that his playing rivaled that
of clara
rockmore the violin prodigy who became a
virtuoso
on this electronic instrument around the
1920s billy also compliments her uncle
bill on his throat singing
calling it a whole new level of
eloquence and some
serious bugakume a reference to one
traditional style of such vocalization
the plot for bill and ted face the music
kicks into gear when another future
representative
played by kristen schall escorts the
guys to their hometown of san dimas in
the year 2720.
there we learned that rufus's prophecy
of the future apparently left out a few
things
as the future's great leader describes
it a song created by preston and logan
at a concert performed by everyone in
the band at 7
17 p.m at mp46 we'll save reality as we
know it
uniting humanity across all time without
that song
time can't hold together blipping
historical figures such as george
washington
babe ruth and even rapper kid cudi all
over the place
but while the great leader scolds bill
and ted for not producing the perfect
tune yet
her math seems to retcon the timeline of
the second film
25 years ago you played a concert in
front of the entire
world a newspaper story about that
concert during the closing credits of
bill and ted's bogus journey places it
in 1991
but bill and ted face the music is set
in 2020.
25 years earlier would be 1995.
whoa screenwriter ed solomon has said
that they had to carefully arrange their
plans for the third movie to fit that
ending montage
which included such titanic
accomplishments as the guys playing on
mars
this wasn't necessarily the writer's
plan though according to solomon
those headlines were added in
post-production without their knowledge
livening up the second movie's ending
while unwittingly stepping on the
planned third movie's toes
while much of that bogus journey credits
material is implied to still have
happened and face the music
the overall result still led to bill and
ted becoming schlubby sort of losers by
the time they reached full dadhood
bill and ted may have won the battle of
the bands but according to the writer
they ended up being more of a flash in
the pan
in the years that immediately followed
under pressure to write the perfect song
within hours
villains had journeyed to the future to
get some help from themselves
while the wardrobe of their future
selves occasionally leaves much to be
desired
the present-day duo has a dad's style
that's only mildly different from what
they wore in the previous films
bill always liked blue hues and plaid or
buttoned down shirts usually worn as
jackets or tied around his waist as they
travel
through time and to heaven and hell here
he again ties a plaid shirt around his
waist and wears a blue wild stallions
t-shirt that has the band's name written
across the back
as for ted he's always liked red in bill
and ted's excellent adventure
ted wears a light red denim jacket
outside the circle k
early in the film when rufus first meets
the pair ted takes off the jacket as
they travel but it's around his waist
for much of the movie
in the second film he wears a red vest
and hoodie combo
in this third film ted starts out
wearing a gray suit jacket and gray
slacks
but as he and bill trek through time he
ditches the jacket
fully revealing a button-down shirt in a
signature color
as they visit various versions of their
future selves villains had at one point
land outside a mansion
bolstering their hopes that they've
written the important song after all
the future bill and future ted inside
aren't the successful rockers they
pretend to be
although they try to dress and act the
part while their outlandish tights
animal prints and top hat might remind
some viewers of guns n roses or
aerosmith in the 1980s
costume designer jennifer stozzic told
variety that she drew from another band
of that era
van halen she imagined bill and ted
imitating the band from its early heyday
when dressing them for the big time
she explained that whole look of the two
was about
over embellishment and how ridiculously
rock star they should look
as if they were famous the present day
heroes soon learn that real rockers are
more low-key when the true homeowner
dave growl of the foo fighters arrives
in an understated black outfit
real rock stars these days look a little
less ridiculous
the filmmakers couldn't resist paying
tribute to george carlin whose time
traveling rufus appeared in both earlier
films
the comedian whose famous riffs included
an extended bit on the dirtiest words
you can't say on television
died in 2008 at age 71. in bill and ted
face the music
rufus returns for a few seconds as a
hologram in san dimas 2720
popping out of the time traveling phone
booth as a sort of historical kiosk
a bigger tribute however is in charles
character her emissary from the future
is rufus's daughter and her name is
kelly
the actual name of the comedian's
daughter in real life writer ed solomon
confirmed the intentional reference on
twitter
writing one of the things george was
proudest of was his daughter kelly
and if you ask me i think he'd have
loved that we named rufus's daughter
kelly
how can we ever thank you rufus well you
can start
by signing this for my kids kelly carlin
also has a small cameo in one of the
film's future scenes
gifting bill and ted with rufus's watch
to keep track of time while on their
journey
the inscription inside sometimes things
don't make sense until the end of the
story
in bill and ted's excellent adventure
the boys didn't visit the library to
work on their history report but sat on
the curb outside the circle k
asking passerby about figures such as
genghis khan
excuse me when did the mongols rule
china
i don't know i just work here then rufus
arrived in the telephone booth amid
crackles of electricity
changing these two charming california
knuckleheads lives forever
strange things are a foot at the circle
k
the convenience store doesn't appear in
bill and ted face the music
but the humble origin of the guy's time
traveling antics does get a shout out as
time and reality
go haywire toward the climax while the
guys their wives their daughters
and fellow musicians puzzle out how and
where they're meant to play the
essential song
sharp-eyed viewers can spot a red circle
k billboard in the background
the circle k callback isn't the only
subtle touch here however
the billboard next to the one
advertising the store says music unites
the theme of all the bill and ted films
an apt description of what our heroes
desperately want to do
although bill and ted's wardrobe choices
echo their earlier films
ted's love of smiley faces deserves a
highlight all its own
as a teen in bill and ted's excellent
adventure ted wore black shorts with a
yellow smiley face patch on one leg
the motif appeared again on the back of
ted's vest and hoodie combo
in bill and ted's bogus journey and also
on the baby carrier holding little bill
that strapped to ted's back before he
and bill play at the climactic battle of
the bands
in bill and ted face to music however
ted's smileys don't show up for a while
sure he's a middle-aged guy at this
point so he might not wear them so
obviously
but considering his best buddy still
knocks around in his band t-shirt
the missing smiley faces comment on
ted's emotional state
the film opens with the pair feeling low
after all wondering if they
failed to live up to their potential but
the film signals that all will work out
eventually when they meet one future ted
who wears a comfortable purple shirt
with smiley faces printed across the
front
he's clearly at peace and by the film's
end as present day bill and ted rock out
with their wives
daughters and the rest of the crowd ted
plays guitar with smiley faces all along
the strap
it's enough to leave the audience in a
happy place check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one